الان مباشره نتحول من جديد الى جيفارا
البوديري الموجوده في اريحا
للحديث عما ذكرته وكاله الانباء
الفلسطينيه حول اصابه ثلاثه فلسطينيين في
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال مخيم عقبه جابر
باريحة
موجوده انت في المنطقه في حواره جيفارا
بعينا في صوره ما يجري حاليا من عمليه
اقتحام على ما يبدو للمخيم من قبل قوات
الاحتلال
نعم حسن بالفعل قوات الاحتلال تحاصر مخيم
عقبه جبر الان في مدينه اريحا من كافه
الاتجاهات وفق مصادر طبيه وايضا وفق عدد
من الصحفيين الذين يحاصرون ايضا في داخل
المخيم هناك تاكيد لاصابه صعبه اصابه شاب
بجراح خطيره الطواقم الطبيه تحاول انعاشه
ولكن يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عرقله عمليه الطواقم الطبيه وقامت باعتقال
الشاب نؤكد ان الشاب وفق شهود عيان مصابه
بجراح خطيره وان قوات الاحتلال قامت
باعتقاله في هذه الاثناء ايضا قوات
الاحتلال رغم حصارها للمخيم ولكن ايضا
هناك لحصار مشدد على مبنى سكني يبدو انه
من طابقين في داخل المخيم ووفق شهود عيان
وايضا عدد من الصحفيين ف يتم الطلب عبر
مكبرات الصوت من قبل جنود الاحتلال لمن هم
في داخل المنزل بتسليم انفسهم بزعمي انهم
مطلبون لدى الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
وفق مصادر اعلاميه اسرائيليه يقول الجيش
وهذا غير مؤكد نحن بانتظار بيان رسمي
الجيش فقط قال ان هناك عمليه عسكريه في
داخل مخيم عقبه جابر ولكن وفق بعض وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه نقلا عن الجيش فان
العمليه هي تدور عن محاوله اعتقال من
اسمتهم بخليه تابعه لحركه حماس ولكن نذكر
هنا ان هذه العمليه اليوم تاتي بعد يومين
من مقتل مستوطن اسرائيلي من قبل مسلحين
فلسطينيين ويبدو ان العمليه تدور الان بعد
وصول معلومات قد يبدو ذلك نحن لسنا
متاكدين من ذلك تدور المعلومات حول الوصول
الى احد منفذي هذه الهجوم ولكن ذلك غير مؤ
من اي جهه حتى اللحظه هناك مواجهات الان
بين شبان فلسطينيين وجنود الاحتلال الذين
يحاصرون المخيم كما ذكرنا من كافه
الاتجاهات واضحه الواضح اخذ بالتصاعدا
هناك نعم حسنا اذا نذكر هنا باصابه ثلاثه
فلسطينيين في اقتحام قوات الاحتلال لمخيم
عقبه جبر
باريحا وبان قوات الاحتلال لاسرائيل وحاصر
منزلا في مخيم عقبه جبر
اشرت الى ان ايضا اشتباكات بين قوات
الاحتلال ومقاومين في
المخيم وان احد
احد الفلسطينيين اصابه حرجه تحاول طواقم
الاسعاف انعاشه حتى الان غير واضح ان كانت
عمليه عسكريه واس عه لكن لدينا صور هنا
مباشره
لقوات الاحتلال قوه الاحتلال تحاصر منزلا
في هذا المخيم